okay watch more
closely
here
watch I don't need
it if you're going like this this hand
is dead then it's dead when you get
here you're trading adion
[Music]
Point you're not going to be able to do
that if it goes dead
and then you try to hit it it doesn't
happen do you keep that
alive so just for training we'll take
this hand out here keep it
[Music]
alive it is
harder it is harder to get it adhesion
going with no inertia going that way
okay because you won't have The
increased pressure so you you can do it
but it's
harder so don't don't
wait keep it going
fluid
[Music]
fluid make sure this
drill that you're not going this
way you're not going there in the
technique we going this way in the
technique but we're not focusing on that
so kind of go straight got it don't take
his base
out okay try that Dr
[Music]
so use your uh y arm to do it not the
not the yin
[Music]
or
contact contact no no
no contact on the young arm
slow it down slow it down contact on
your right arm bring use the right hand
to bring it no use the right hand to
bring him into the right arm there it is
out that's
it then you can add the other hand but
it's not the dominant hand try it again
bring in left hand brings them in good
out that's it that's the drill two more
don't worry about the
[Music]
entring there you
go don't hook them with your
elbow don't hook with your elbow so it's
a inward spiral so don't over articulate
the elbow you don't need a right angle
in your
[Music]
elbow no no no no no no no no no no no
start over don't let your elbow go
behind
you
enter no no no he his head goes on your
arm
[Music]
you're trying for a shoulder leverage
okay we're not we're not going to use
shoulder
leverage slow down bring stop you
brought him to your
shoulder don't bring him to your
shoulder bring his head to your arm head
to your arm stop now put just scoot back
a little Ronin please where you came
from don't let your arm go behind you
okay wait relax now and hear on his chin
with your arm
and step out to your right with your
right foot then enter that's what we're
working
[Music]
on bring him go don't let your arm
behind
you
enter okay I don't really want you
throwing them in the direction we do
have a x pattern we're going to do
eventually you don't have to go that far
as you did don't follow the the uh
single axis
out back
it got
it
out you need to start putting it
together arm keep going use your arm for
the Y yield your arm not your right
hand you stop go
back Slow Down slow down so I can talk
all right see your left hand use your
left hand to BR her head into your left
arm then step out to the side and in you
[Music]
go don't go behind
you don't go backwards
stop using that
[Music]
arm there you
go no don't cut down on him you want him
to come in you want his Center to come
up so you just bring his head in
[Music]
so he's coming in for you which is not
incorrect but you're not doing the drill
right so you're snaking around his hand
and you want to adhere to his
hand that hand pulls them
in and then you got to do it
all there you go that's it
[Music]
don't don't hke
it
good don't let it behind you
[Music]
throw with the adhesion keep the
adhesion there you
go there you
go that's it no no no don't go to her
[Music]
wait you're like don't trust
her wait why did you keep changing your
speed
here here
[Music]
going this this
stop in
there it is you see how I did that and
now
your we're moving this SP okay there it
is I keep the feeling in
[Music]
this is how you would do it you're not
going to throw her right so she I bring
her in there it is and
[Music]
okay
try yes stay in yourself not not in you
all
right yes
[Music]
have to ground right it's a bigger dude
been having a lot of
tension you kind do the
arm just don't do the x pattern don't do
the base
displacement oh what wa why is your arm
so
straight it's a inward spiral ouward
Spiral so I don't have a locked elbow
you but that's what is making you snake
around their
arms lock Bel theater snake style come
on
your arms slow down get rid of that
tension you have a outward spiral
starting on the left hand together on
the on the on the midpoint on the chest
okay so my elbow should be anchored on
my left hand and as I'm coming up to to
Chon level my hand should start going
out my elbow stays
anchored do you get it and you let him
come up to your to your arm bring your
arm up let him touch it you picked him
up
[Music]
though elbow why you keep snaking around
that it's killing me
hey all right so you see you're here
like this and then you go like
that you you're going to control you're
going to control this
arm then you're going tool contr this
head okay
and control the
arm then the
head
[Music]
now arm head
don't come
[Music]
in I'm going to go to Chris now okay
okay Chris so when I'm there I don't
worry about him I feel the energy okay I
feel the energy
[Music]
do the energy right so I don't want to
lose the feeling on my
arm cuz I want to see how his legs
coming forward and that's what I
ultimately
[Music]
want okay
try all right
uh because we ultimately want to get to
like teni net or or AI nugget you have
to be
careful with how you bring him
into your arm so you bring him with a
step back you see you don't have much Ed
[Music]
me also as your foot is going
back you don't really have much Yin
yield this way
okay so if you paid attention I do what
I always do just like the hand workk we
were doing right so I had him coming
into uh around me you see and then I
enter here we did that on the last video
meaning he's going around me I'm not
really
going going around
him
okay uh and kind of a rule I have is
it's not a stance change is not Ed
me you didn't actually Traverse forward
so that's not EDI okay so what I'm doing
here is this fight is going to rotate
you see and now I have my as I do my
face displacement you see how far I can
go
okay which means the right foot in this
drill is going to go
out not
back
okay which also means that the forward
progress
initiates on a weight shift for him his
forward progress is on the weight
shift then
out shift
out okay so part of the problem is is
that you'll
picturing
this you you're picturing bending them
backwards but that's not the throw
that's not the throwing mechanics okay
so without the without the Ed he kind of
just goes around me do you get it it's
just like a a
little such that he could actually walk
out of it he could walk out of
it see you get it that's why you need
the thing in there it's the same way
like here if you doesn't want me to bend
him backwards he's
not he not bending them backwards okay
do you get it so you don't try to bend
him backwards the technique that you're
going to do is going to just do that
same
turn that you saw him walk out of only
his legs are going the other way with
the
entry okay so in this
drill make
sure that you're not trying to bend them
because when you do that that's where
you're getting this up you're coming
towards
him you should be
feeling
this this is what you're
feeling that's what you're feeling
that's all we're feeling this little
loop on his head
okay all right so you're trying to get
him to uh to keep going forward that's
why you don't you don't bring your arm
here and your hand Goes West it doesn't
go west it keeps coming this way boom he
hit it okay then that's now I have his
body now I move his
body in the movement you're going to
keep that Center has to keep going
forward so you can't come this way you
have to keep that Center going ever so
slightly
forward so that's your little U shape
here your half
[Music]
moon right we we always Half Moon we
have Moon just like an
e you don't go here and
Out Half Moon back
out then he goes forward still watch
watch it Center now in the movement it's
going forward it's going to go
forward and watch my foot my foot comes
back and then
out but not back and
back and at this rate my foot's actually
going back and
forward not out it's front of the other
foot okay
um
also when we're here like
that okay it's the back foot that's
grounding so if he's pushing on me we're
not going anywhere he's pushing pushing
pushing pushing pushing pushing we're
not going
anywhere he's pushing this way where
your head would be okay we're not going
anywhere so I don't I don't have to
panic and go back at him this adhesion
is what I'm using his pressure
so
stop trying to contest it you want it
the better the tighter that is fine cool
bigger
movements okay but you have to ground
that foot so that the other foot can
move in the you shap try